ich habe ein paar von den verlorenen bzw
retourierten 5000 DL Paketen zu den
Empfängern zurückgebracht und ja das war
der zweite dude der hat so eine
SmartWatch bestellt so eine Dropshipping
SmartWatch billig SmartWatch aus China
ich habe ihm dann noch eine teure
SmartWatch gekauft um die ihm zusätzlich
zu schenken
[Musik]
dann bin ich da hingefahren und das war
seine Reaktion hallo hi ich habe hier
einen also erstmal ganz kurz ich habe
hier ein Paket für Sie
das ist ich erkläre ihn kurz die
Geschichte dahinter ich habe ganz viele
Pakete aufgekauft unter anderem war auch
Iris dabei sie haben irgendwas
zurückgeschickt und die landen dann
nicht mehr direkt beim Verkäufer sondern
werden manchmal so gesammelt und die
Leute die bei mir in der Nähe wohnen den
bringe ich das jetzt einfach wieder
zurück plus noch ein kleines Geschenk
also sie hatten hier glaube ich so eine
SmartWatch bestellt aber so ich habe
jetzt einfach mal hier eine neue gekauft
die schenke ich dir